hello hello
it's on are you sure it's on those red
lights
red light district oh my god scanceless
hold on let's do like a nieces let's do
it oh cheers
[Laughter]
oh no in case you're wondering my name
is margaret cho no relation however a
relation to grace helbig i am her aunt
and i am main results
whoa
onomatopoeia you better not appear on a
mia
it was a bad experience it was an
applebee's the one that we don't go back
to anymore she's snuck in a guinea pig
you had me hold it in my lap you got a
little [ __ ] pissed everywhere look i
was taking it for a test drive petsmart
let me take it out of the facility take
it to applebee's my stomping grounds it
didn't do what it said it was supposed
to do which is to just sit there and be
a support animal anyway anyway hello
hello we are grace the memories on yeah
and we are here we're having a little
corpse here oh
we just got off work we are two
librarians and that place now is jumping
pumping four people there today oh they
were checking out books they were giving
us looks i was like oh excuse me can i
get a raise this place is busy i'm going
home exhausted i mean i know what uh
nieces go through of being on around
people because i felt like i was giving
them the full experience of a librarian
you kidding me i i made the mistake
of going to the children's section today
it was basically a meet and greet they
said miss trembles this troubles read or
something i said learn to read you
little shits yeah i didn't i but i
wanted to when i thought of it because
with the sh
speaking of children and art yeah there
was an event that happened that is
cultural phenomenon to say the least if
you guys are living under a rock first
of all god bless i hope you get your
life together second of all the biggest
party monday of the year oh it was and
not labor day oh labor day that's a big
monday and it's a big monday but what do
you think on the labor day you do you
don't labor you don't labor you know
though i do though because you know i
throw my annual pig picking yeah yeah
and i it's not what it sounds like i
throw a party for everyone all i do is
work i know i know you really you're
never off the clock i don't know where
you sleep or how you sleep i don't it's
one of those mysteries it's like a da
vinci code i'll never know last night
was the mets gala oh
the night where the stars come to shine
and we are confused and we don't know oh
okay what so what the heck did we just
see what's going on here in fashion and
how much lsd is being consumed by
everyone thank you
there's a lot of things going on it's
like going to a children's puppet
theater oh my god that is so true and no
one's laughing like everyone's very
serious about what's going on they say
we're an artist we're famous we we have
better taste than you and i said better
taste than me do you know why i got this
clearance 6.99
6.99 at marshalls marshalls she went to
tj maxx first they only had grey
marshalls i got this 2.99 it already had
makeup stained on it at ross dressed for
less i said you know what i'll keep the
makeup stains i was going to do it to it
anyway yeah don't be so crazy about
stains it's lived in you know when
people get jeans and they're like oh
it's all lived in already oh it's got oh
oh they feel good nice i mean just wear
some sweatpants you know what else they
do they try to upsell you on and
charging money they say these jeans have
been distressed i'll show you someone's
been distressed working at the library
with the amount of people that now
decide that they enjoy reading yeah the
only way i'm de-stressed is one of these
quotes oh
hello
cherry blossom daiquiris oh delicious i
was watching the metaphor and i first of
all i didn't know who anyone was i have
no idea who any of these people are and
i'm curious if they know who they are
where is where black are at oh bingo
bird hump a dink all the danks tom jones
not enough dinks these days hollywood if
you ask me you know what really makes
you think i want some sexy men up there
who is this anderson park anderson park
do you have a throat issue no okay no
even though i did just give her a
haircut there's people there when i say
who are you and why aren't you sexy i
like my celebrities sexy it's always a
theme which we love because we love
categorizing things we love when things
are decidedly what they're supposed to
be and we love themes dress-ups too we
have spirit week at our library we have
crazy hair day remember we wore pigtails
oh we said check out this crazy hair you
think i got a ponytail no it's two
pigtails two of them at one point you'd
say we snuck a little bit of rumple
mints and we tied a ponytail together oh
and we walked so we walked in the
library we did like
we're doing a three-legged race oh but i
don't think i'm watching this people oh
my god hold on i'm gonna do it i'm gonna
do it people
understood the assignment whoa whoa
i've been wow i learned about this lying
field she's been telling me this on our
lunch break all day about how she has
this idea of using this phrase in this
video and i can't believe you did it and
it perhaps i mean it sounded like you
understood your assignment you did it
too
oh that's crazy but so me and my bestest
friend right here margaret cho are going
to look at some of the outfits yeah and
decide what do we think about them but
these two old boards have seen a lot in
their life we've seen trends come go
throw no yo and so we say well let's
let's see let's let's see the assignment
let's see what's going on here because i
constantly feel like i'm living in a bit
of a fantasy and if well you read a lot
of fantasy books yeah we never even we
can't even rent them at the library
because she just has them at that at her
house
i'm allowed i'm allowed if there's a
male nipple on a cover it's at her house
is that my house is that my house i got
stacks of nipples all right so let's see
what these celebrities were wearing to
an event which i guess the idea is that
they just show up in clown clothes and
then we all go yay okay i think we go oh
check it out they're having us
distracted from our useless existence oh
yes for one month
for one night so they're all wearing
what's the theme this year guilted age
one more time the gilded age okay killed
in eight which i believe means like you
know it was like a time in new york city
when everyone was really rich and like
people it was all access it was like the
80s of the 1800s gilded age
okay age see i'm already confused so i
i reserve some uh a judgment that
everyone might be very confused yep
absolutely all right let's look at who
we have here
okay
okay we've got sarah jessica parker or
some people call her sjp wow
i mean when you go by just initials you
are really establishing yourself in
society as someone that has monogrammed
towels yeah oh absolutely you know she
does yeah
wow wow she's wearing a flannel shirt as
a big old ball gal jerry grunge what is
on her head okay this is what i'd like
to talk about yeah this to me if you
said to me if that was not on her head
yeah if it was on a table i'd say how
much did you get that centerpiece from
party city for yeah this looks like all
right i went to a bachelorette party
pulled the penises out because i
realized the mat was going right and
then i was like oh let me put this on my
head and here we go i'm fashioned now
she looks like she's going to a bachelor
met oh look at that also you know what i
noticed she's wearing a watch oh she is
wearing a watch she doesn't need to know
what time it is it's sjp we live on her
torn the only people that wear watches
are fathers i thought for the watches
have you ever worn something that
exposes yeah oh this oh god and then it
covers your this and then it keeps your
wrists out so you can look at your wrist
watch when you need to she has a lot of
delicatessen showing up here
what decolletage
something about she's got a declaration
happening she's got a declaration of
independence up here uh-huh skin is
revolting from the fabric close i think
if i had my shoulders exposed i would be
turning myself on i am i'd be like oh oh
that's coming out what if my shoulders
are exposed that means that you're
bailing me out of the drunk tank because
they have to show up they have not been
exposed since like the 80s early 80s
let's do it we got bella hot and bella
whoa whoa
whoa
whoa
i thought that was gilded age not an
extra from blade two whoa
yeah this woman i'm scared of her has
had blood recently what is the theme
again and why is what is the theme is it
goth girl who won the lottery what so
what happened to the little things what
is that little thing what are those
little things what are the little things
what are the little things those look
like worms i feel like she's oh she's
just gonna warm something up is that is
that fashion now that's fashion what are
these little warm brain warm bangs no
offense but i feel like okay this is
what i look like when i get out of the
shower wow that's very confident i have
a pleather robe that i use on my all
days hold on she's wearing pearls around
her ankle
it says she is wearing a brownie raymond
pearl necklace as an anklet that's
absolutely absurd that's absurd here's
the thing i don't mind an anklet
margaret cho knows when we go to key
west
after i have a couple a couple of pina
coladas literally two i go let's go get
toe rings every time but a pearl
necklace you're out of your mind on your
ankle while you're on gilded age homo
house arrest it's like little women
gotta stay home because they did
something bad that's a lot of talk like
she can't sit down of course you know
what i've never i've never loved the
course i've never seen a corset that i
liked i would rather have a college
course i'd like to have a full course
meal okay there we go all right here we
go jared lego oh oh lego and alessandro
oh
okay so everyone else has seen that
there's two of them we have finished a
drink but you are not seeing double okay
these are two human boys i think the
okay jared which one's which oh my god
this is the guy last year he came to the
met ball holding his own head he had a
he got a second head made and he carried
it around like a place oh he likes him
some spoons a little attention he likes
to do things a little bit different you
know here's the thing i think everyone
at this event likes a little attention
that'll tell you what's true this is
like we tried to do a twins day at the
library where we coordinated and we like
i mean they really nailed it
they're like the shining twins
area can i just say the brown part and
the gloves with the black not good my
mama told me three things what she said
don't wear white afterlife again don't
wear brown with black mother and i'll be
back later and jerry
until those things have become true two
of those things were correct
okay jared legos good for you and your
long ass hair i mean the good thing is
that they already seemed to have come to
the event knowing that they were going
to be wearing the same right they didn't
show up and go oh no oh you're also
wearing the weird suit with the long
hair with the glasses with the brown
purple oh you've made also all these
specifically strange choices oh and gone
off faces they look like caterers that
have been
taking lsd unbelievably correct also is
that a stunt double i don't know is that
a stunt honestly i don't know would he
take a bullet for him i will tell you
that i don't know what's going on here
but i will say instinctually it makes me
uncomfortable
someone plans on uh a night at the
museum i guess is the sleepover part of
this she's wearing a very rich sleeping
bag she's ripped for her pleasure whoa
eat okay okay how mad would you be if
you were at the movie yeah and someone
came in and like oh and just swish swish
swish swish swish swish
and just takes up half your seat you're
under a blanket that coat is too big is
it just that they go and stand on the
stairs and then they go home
i think there's a dinner there's some
halloween this is impossible this is
absolute does the coat have its own
table right how does this happen she
looks like a charcuterie board yeah she
looks a bit like a vagina she looks like
a prolapsed anus yeah oh look i didn't
want to say it and i know you were
thinking it because we've had this
conversation real recently about what
they look like and we did a little
googling yeah we and you cannot see it
once you see it we went to the
encyclopedia we said oh god it's on page
742 questions
and then we will back it out back and
then we're back at outback just to sue
the woes okay here we have one oh we
have a couple a couple okay we have kim
kardashian and pete davidson
she brought i think she brought the
valet boy oh that's her date that's very
nice that's very nice she loves to hear
it they appreciate the work that people
do for you she said oh no i'm out of
fives i can't tip you for the car you
know what though i've got a plus one
would you like to come with me sir and
he said no problem i quit also it seems
she's also having a bit of
gastrointestinal distress at least in
this picture i don't know listen she
chose not to have a billowy dress so you
can sell her farts she's letting out
like like me that's why you got the
[Music]
i'm a maxinista so i'm going to give you
some fashion advice okay do it when
you're wearing a tight piece and you
know you're still gonna be gone with the
wind in the back you gotta have a fake
wrap to wrap around your butt like what
in case your dress goes
[Music]
what is the thing that she's wrapping
around herself if not a filter for her
thoughts oh my god this facts you ready
for this yeah ready for this okay
she is wearing the dress
that marilyn monroe wore when she sang
happy birthday mr president
happy birthday
to you
that's the art that is the dress
that marilyn monroe wore all those years
ago when singing to
my wet dream jfk
you know monogrammed i'll never get over
it that's that real dress it's a part of
history and she's just wearing it and
farting all night in it
someone called the police
absolutely absurd
absolutely absurd i saw and people said
how did she get to wear it i did a
little research oh of course research
and in hard caption
caption
on a thing okay on the thing got it
guess who she thanks for loaning the
dress ripley's believe it or not
you know what i can't believe how much
she's ripping ass in this thing all
night so i gotta take it back they say
believe it or not she
lamb vindaloo
she had the crab rangoon i would never
want to wear anyone else's historical
piece because i know once again my
gastrointestinal system and i'm going to
be ripping for it's all night in this
rip it believe it or not yeah a thousand
percent oh my god what that was fun okay
i can't keep looking at this stuff
because it's really taking me from my
own sense of reality oh my god if you
want to watch a couple more of these go
over to my niece's channel you deserve a
drink and we do after watching that
stuff oh my god how do we get an invite
where do they go when they're not on the
stairs there's a dinner
the second i passed the threshold of the
front doors i would be in sweatpants i
said take me
take this bustle and someone's gonna
have to get this really dry cleaned
because some shit's happened in here she
had the crab rangoon
was it
[Music]
rangoon